welcome to alpha this vide of a thousand  planets Alex can you update us I'd be  delighted to the Alpha station has grown  7% this year and since it left the  terrestrial orbit it has traveled almost  700 million miles population almost 30  million 3236 species from the four  corners of the universe live on board  pooling their knowledge and cultures  over 5,000 languages spoken  not counting the various computer  languages demographics to the south are  the submerged parts with 800 species  living in all kinds of liquids such as  the peaceful colon farmers who grow  cobalt to the north we have gaseous land  dominated by the edema  whose extreme sensitivity makes them  specialists and neurosciences and  molecular components they can build  cells of any kind to the east of the  large colony of on light they control  information technology finance and  banking finally to the west in a  pressurized atmosphere we have 9 million  humans and compatible species home sweet  home  you